[Music]
on today's show we talked to a woman
whose husband invited his teenage
brother to live with them without asking
her
we also talked to a woman who's
struggling with her mom's mental health
diagnosis and what this means for her in
the future
we also talk about the changing picture
of relationships in america stay tuned
[Music]
can't you see i'm easily i'm bothered by
persistence
one step dude i introduced my son to
some metal last night
[Music]
didn't end great
i realized i just did an opera version
of a pantera song that's not great
either for any of us hey this is dr john
dolone's show so glad you're here
great
spec james we got to do that we got to
have a super metal band like a super
group metal band
and really just you and me white stripe
style be incredible
i'm down kelly will you be in it
no
well there's there there went that
man hey on this show we talk about
mental health relationships and old
metal songs so glad that you're with us
if you want to be on this show give me a
shout at
1-844-693-3291 that's
1-844-693-3291 or go to johndaloni.com
ask
we'll get you on the show
if
the gatekeeper kelly says so let's go to
joy in
west palm beach what's up joy
hi
how are you i'm so good how are you a
little bit nervous to be honest but
listen here we go i'm not great at this
you're you're you're good it's good
what's up
um so
my husband and i have been talking about
moving to another state in the next year
or two and currently his younger brother
is living with us
but when we move i'd really prefer if
his brother did not come and i don't
know how to talk to him about it or even
if i have a i have a right to even ask
that
so
man you just told me a lot in like two
sentences
how how much can i unpack that how
what's your what's your permission level
whatever you need to
ask why
in all of the world
do you think you don't have a right to
ask
about who lives in your home
what has happened is
it is
but what has happened in that dynamic
between the two of you
that makes you even say that out loud
um
well he lives with us
with it was kind of without my
permission
his family had asked
um if he would be able to come live with
us and my husband just automatically
said yes without ever talking to me
about it and so i just kind of feel
thrown into this yeah
how long have you all been married
six years
where else does he do this
um
i mean that's like your biggest thing
but make unilateral decisions just this
is the way we're doing it
um
[Music]
be honest
not i mean he doesn't he doesn't really
do anything like that that
big scale and uh i mean that's like the
biggest thing but i'm talking about
little stuff i mean
yeah
um
sometimes with our
our finances just he i mean like we we
have the same end goal but he doesn't
always the day-to-day he kind of
sometimes loses sight of that and just
or not trying to
you know get us keep us on a budget and
keep us going to the you know where
we're trying to go and he just will be
at a store and see something and go oh i
want to buy this and buy it
so
there
that's probably
i mean that's probably the biggest thing
it took you a lot of courage to call
about this didn't it
yeah yeah
this isn't what you asked me so i'm just
gonna answer what you asked me but i am
gonna say this
um
and i will admit i have a bias to this
okay
i i
would rather be wrong than right
meaning
um i would rather
hear something that's not really there
on this than to miss it completely
but i hear a little bit of fear in your
voice
a little bit of futility a little bit of
i need to protect him
and i need to keep whatever our story is
our story
and what i want you to hear me say is if
that's the case
please
look in the mirror this afternoon or
this morning whenever you want to
you don't need another guy telling you
what to do
but
i want you to look in the mirror and say
i'm worth
being a co-partner in this deal
and go talk to somebody okay
i may be way out to lunch
but
there's something in your voice that is
setting my radar off okay
and i'm telling you that because i love
you okay
so when it comes to
you've got it how old is this little
brother
he's 17.
okay
so
again in a
quasi-normal dynamic
i would sit down and say
he's been with us for this many years
three years is that right
yes three out of six so 50 of our
marriage has had a teenager in it
that's your brother
i'm ready to have our own home
and so
i am not interested in him
moving with us this time i think we've
done our duty we've done our part
and other people in the house can step
up or he's about to be 18 he is can be
ready to be on his own
and i would like our own house as we
move
that's would be a symbol of conversation
and then probably the pushback would be
no he's my brother he's got to do
whatever
and
that's when you would talk more about
the last three years i haven't had a
voice in this i feel like i've not uh
i'm not a participant in my own home
and this is my home too
and i'm all about helping and loving and
if we want to support him financially
and whatever the things are but i'm
ready to have my own home please
and not please in a
please pretty please like like my son
asked me for girl scout cookies but
please as in a
i'm trying to be pleasant as i'm telling
you this is the way i want to move
forward
something tells me you can't have that
conversation you wouldn't be calling me
so what is the conversation like in your
home
well
we we do have our own kids
and
it's always like oh but
they love him like they love having him
around of course
and i'm like yeah but
i mean it's just and we just
so we have we just had our our third
baby
three months ago so we now have six of
us living in
a two bedroom like 850 square foot
living space
townhouse what
that's a lot of humans and not a lot of
square footage
exactly
and so that's like another reason why
i'm like i'm ready for our space i'm
ready to have you know i want
my family
yes and
what keeps you from saying it out loud
i think i just i feel guilty and like
like
maybe i'm a
bad person for not
it's not that like i don't want to help
him but at the same time
like i guess i feel like i'm being
selfish where did you learn that
somebody taught you that
that the way you feel and what you need
to make your house whole and what you
need to be well
is selfish
somebody told you that who told you
that i don't know
usually that story is a story that we
are told when we're young we're born
into it
you be quiet this is where we're going
to eat you shut your mouth
you sit back there we don't wear clothes
like that in this house you wear that
only girls who don't care about how they
look eat that stuff don't eat that
we're like this
my little brother's moving in with this
by the way need to make room
and those are stories that are just
dumped into on on to us man and so if
i'm the first person to ever tell you
this shame on everyone around you
but you're allowed to have your thoughts
and your feelings and you're allowed to
have your emotions and you're allowed to
say this is what i need to be well
and we have three of our own ki five
people and 850 square foot feet is a
lot a lot
not to mention a newborn in all the
diapers and breastfeeding and yelling
and crying
that's a lot of humans
and you throw a 17 year old where's his
parents
uh well
they're from another country so his mom
is in their home country and he came to
the us to live with us ah so now we got
a cultural element on this yes all right
totally different now okay
oh man
just for my own edification are you safe
joy
yes
you promise
yes okay
we often think of safety as physical
safety am i going to get punched in the
eye
i want you to start thinking about
safety also being
spiritual safety psychological safety
does your voice count
can you say hey this is what i need and
i'm heard
now i also want to be i mean
the way i was talking earlier i was
talking very ethnocentric very much
western this is the way we do family
and i know all there's a number of
different cultures that do the family
looks different
right and brothers and sisters and
cousins are all living with us and
that's just the way we do life
what i hope you can do is have a
conversation with your husband about
this is what i need and he will hear
that
but it is absolutely not selfish for you
to be heard
for you to state your needs out loud
in fact that's a gift in fact what i
would tell you is
hurting all day
feeling like you are a stranger in your
own home
distances yourself from your husband
from your kids from family
and so if you i don't think that's i
mean if you want to start thinking
selfish think that way
choosing to not speak up when i don't
feel safe or loved and or connected in
my own house
that's got ramifications too
okay so here's i would take him out i
would have a hard conversation a gentle
conversation a respectful loving
conversation that just says i need i
need to have my own house with my own
family and it's time for your brother to
do his own thing
or at least we got to get a way way way
bigger house with a garage apartment or
something right
when you're moving you're getting a new
place
more space
yeah
yeah well that's the thing too because
if he were to move with us and i feel
like we would need an even bigger house
because he would need his own space and
so i'm just like
thinking about all of the
you know
all of those types of things too
yeah and it's just
you sound um
you sound lonely
is that the wrong word
no
okay
stay on the line here i'm gonna send you
a copy of
my new book we talk about this stuff all
through it okay not the cultural
challenges that you've got and there is
a cultural gap here
um is your husband usually respectful
when you bring up cultural differences
and you'll say hey how are we going to
navigate this because your refusing
cultures here
and part of using cultures is just
navigating the differences
or does his culture trump every time
you know i think like he's open to
talking about it he just doesn't always
understand i think he has a hard time
really understanding it okay
and so
i've talked i just fact i just talked
about this in the last podcast
one of the great ways when there's a
miscommunication this way
think about it this way we often
speak in pictures
i mean we speak in words but we think in
pictures okay
so you have a picture of quote unquote
my house
what i feel safe
and you tell your husband i just want my
own house
and he's got a picture of what
own house means and it includes cousins
and nephews and brothers and all kind of
people in it it's got a picture of it
and often when we're talking past our
loved ones
it's a matter of painting a new picture
for them
here is a picture it's me being able to
walk around in my own home without a bra
on without a head covering on
in my underwear to go grab something out
of the dryer being in my own home means
not having to cover up every time i walk
out of my bedroom
it means
that i'm allowed to keep it clean is the
way i want to keep it does that make
sense like you're painting him a picture
of oh i didn't even think about that
i didn't even oh my goodness i didn't
even realize that that i want to have my
friends over i want to have
buddies over with and they bring their
little kids over we want to play we got
the 17 year old here it's painting a
different picture for for your husband
and
um
most of the time if two people love each
other
painting a new picture people go oh my
ah i didn't even see it i'm so sorry
and then there's some grieving like i
did i totally missed it i'm so sorry
but the other side of it is
man sometimes it's hard and they
somebody says nope they're living with
me
and then you've got a hard decision to
make
i'm going to be really optimistic here
that you got a great husband who is
just absent-minded and hasn't thought
through it didn't even occur to him the
struggles you're going on sharing a
house with
two grown men
right or a grown man and an almost grown
man
that a new picture paint form would be
really helpful
thanks for the call joy
and command
three kids and a 17 year old and a
husband and a wife
in a two-bedroom apartment
story at 11.
we'll be right back
hey good folks and friends and listeners
to the dr john de loni show
the world is bonkers right we all know
this and one of the most common
questions i get is how do i find a
counselor in the chaos i've reached out
and there's a six month waiting list or
i can't afford it or they only take
insurance or i can't get off work and
time to go see somebody it's way across
town what do i do because i want help
with my anxiety my depression my
relationships are hanging on by a thread
i want to be a better mom i gotta
process this trauma that happened to me
when i was a kid
where do i find a counselor
so i partnered with better help because
betterhelp is customized online therapy
that offers video phone even live chat
sessions so you don't even have to look
at your therapist when you're talking to
them if you don't want to i've taken
away all your excuses and it's more
affordable than in-person therapy and
these are real licensed therapists if
you reach out to them you will be
talking to somebody within 48 hours dr
john delaney show listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
please reach out if you need help that's
betterhelp.com
all right let's go to marie in
winston-salem which trial is north
carolina what's up marie
hi dr delany how are you good how are
you
good i have an interesting one for you i
love it bring it on let's do it
okay so my mother has something called
schizoaffective disorder oh when did she
get diagnosed
uh diagnosed
about five years ago but she has been
bipolar her whole life yeah how long did
she how long did she navigate that
before
you finally got a stab that usually
people who are diagnosed with that
there's just a wake of trauma
in all the family systems before people
finally land on what actually is going
on
so she is the fourth generation of my
family with that diagnosis
and
when i was about my entire childhood she
was a rock star i mean she was an
international uh businesswoman
um six figure income just blowing it out
of the water right
when i was 16 something happened nobody
can conclusively say what
and the wake of trauma is about 13 years
she started thinking people were
following her she started thinking
people were planting bugs on her and
from someone who was achieving that high
everybody believed her for a while and
then so you understand she got on
disability we almost lost our home you
know you understand the finances oh yeah
yeah
and um now they're on a steady
disability her and my father are on a
steady disability but
she has just tanked slowly over time i'm
so sorry
is what's her so let me let me pause
here for everybody listening
schizoaffective disorders uh is
think um
it's like a two-layer sandwich of
no maybe it's maybe it's a it's a
burrito and the filling is
psychosis so hallucinations people are
chasing me people are following me a a
dysregulated reality
wrapped up in
either
super high mania
something very similar to bipolar or
long brutal depressive episodes what is
your mom's is she's got the psychosis
does she
just bury herself or does she get real
manic
she does actually really neat cycles
that's the one blessing we were given
she sticks to her cycles
winter and summer are down fall and
spring are up great okay so there's some
sort of predictive nature to it
a little bit of the mania the the
delusions coming uh the the bugs and the
fbi are pretty solid okay the other ones
tend to come and go you got your got
your gold standard there and let's be
honest yeah exactly um can we really
trust the bugs or the fbi let's i mean
come on marie
wow and there's no lab test for this and
so this usually goes undiagnosed for
years and years and years and like you
mentioned you said it perfectly
it's a slow descent into madness
that is propped up by the people around
you
right and then you start thinking you're
crazy and your dad thinks what am i what
am i losing it and all of a sudden
everybody finds himself in the mud a
little bit right
yes everybody a little bit at the time
and right now she's uh basically
agoraphobic she won't leave the house
because if she does leave the house
they'll come in and put stuff down right
so that's an overview
what type of care has she
gone after
she has gone after she's a religious
medication she there's no issue she
doesn't palm she pills down the throat
it's great for her she's got
she once a month therapy we're starting
with her
she's been institutionalized several
times when things get real bad
and she has been acutely suicidal
suicide no she's afraid of death
but she has had episodes
where she has thought they were there
and she went and got it done because she
wasn't going to let him take her alive
gotcha okay
so it's less internal
oriented violence but external okay
yeah
um
yeah
and this isn't going on i'm 29 this has
been going on since i was 16.
um and i love my mother just as much now
as i did when i was 16. let's make that
clear
um
everyone wants me to accept that mom is
just gonna be this way
and
i have a hard time with that
um and i don't know what to do with the
tension i see because my father they've
been married 36 years he's her full he
doesn't work he's a full-time caretaker
and it hurts me when there's tension in
their marriage
like when i walk in and there because
you know people with that disorder can
get aggressive like dementia
and when they pop back and forth between
the two of them it kills me because they
it wasn't like that growing up there was
they were really really good you know
and then the last one that's the kicker
is there's been one kind of strong
bipolar each generation that has
kind of progressed over into this
and i got the lucky gene
and congratulations
and i don't know how to cope with
the possibility that i'm watching my
future gotcha
i just tell you thank you so much for
being brave and vulnerable and telling
your story
because i i want to generalize this now
to people who are listening
it's easy to listen to your story marie
and say oh my gosh can you imagine
but almost all of us have someone in our
family with alzheimer's or dementia or
obesity or a temper problem
and we all wonder
when does this happen to me
right when when do i
hit somebody when do i go off the rails
when do i start drinking
two too many and then three two right so
all of us have what you're describing
yours is just very acute and very
unknown and very very scary right
because yours feels out of control i
cannot drink it's hard when you're
looking at what's happening to your mom
and so
let's let's work from
oh man
let's work from childhood back or
childhood forward okay
okay i want you to give your body
a lot of grace because your body has a
memory
of a brilliant savant connected fun mom
it remembers that and it is constantly
looking for that again
yeah and it's a never-ending search and
so everything that's not that
cognitively you can know it but it
doesn't feel right
you get what i'm saying
it feels disoriented your body's never
connected when you're with your mom
you're never safe you're always waiting
you're always this this this this you
can't lean into it your body's circling
back for when's normal when's normal
when's normal when's normal
my guess is i'd be willing to bet you
and i don't have a lot of money so it
would be a really lame yet that your
childhood wasn't as rosy as you remember
it
is that fair
i think my parents uh she traveled a lot
so
for her work
and they did a really and i know this
sounds corny
i'm gonna think about that after we get
off the call hey don't explain you're
talking to me there is no corny we're
good
they did i lived in the middle of about
a thousand acres that was divided up
amongst all of our extended family okay
and so when mom went dad stayed home
and we saw her every morning and every
night
there was when i listened to other calls
they said oh my mom went off and did
this or my
that i it wasn't there
i remember when it started because it
was so different from the behavior that
had been there previously okay
um yeah well she was absent a lot
because it was she was gone working but
you had family connectivity that you
were rooted to right
yes yes
and you also have
woven through the genetic fabric and
behavioral fabric experiential fabric of
your family
mental illness that's generations old
right
yes yes and so
my guess is you had a
your dad is some kind of saint is that
fair
yes he sounds like an incredible man
um what you just described to me
externally i'm gonna be super unfair is
that okay we're we're friends just
picture you and me we're at a bar we're
hanging out i'm gonna be unfair but no
i'm doing with a smile on my face okay
okay
what you just described to me a thousand
acre place
with generations it sounds like a
compound
it sounds like a family compound that we
have hidden ourselves into the woods
which sounds very much like the bugs in
the fbi we're gonna hide out here and
create a family is that am i onto
something
yeah okay even my friends always joked
when they came over that we were a
closed society there there you go right
it's like an m night shyamalan movie
right so you're you've got this you've
got this thing so uh here's what i want
to tell you
the
instability you see in your mom
my guess is has threads all throughout
your childhood
and that doesn't negate the fact that
you love this woman and it breaks your
heart to see her like this
and it is stone terrifying to think this
is where i end up
one of the gaps we have when we're
grieving what used to be and what is
is that we
lionize what used to be so great or it
was so awful
and this is so great or this is so bad
and sometimes when you're working with
it helps to flatten it out and to really
dig into the truth of some of the
narratives it it doesn't make it any
better that your mom's struggling like
it is but it makes you feel less bonkers
and it lets your body not be so reactive
like oh
this is how this is manifesting this now
but we were on a trajectory here
and so
there's something about just accepting
mom i i don't like that language that's
your mom
what i do like is
grieving
saying i had this picture when i was 13
i see my friends and their moms
i wanted my mom to be somebody that was
gonna be all excited about my wedding
and that we could go to the store and
then we could drink a little bit too
much with and we could she could tell me
dirty jokes and i'd be like mom don't
say that i had that picture of my mom
and it's not gonna happen
and let your body feel that
that's grief
that's ownership of it and it sucks
it hurts so bad
and when you can do that over a period
of time this isn't a one-shot thing this
is a way of being
a acknowledgement and internalization
then it's not about accepting just the
way mom is you know i accept that the
economy crashes i can't think about it i
don't know i didn't do anything it just
crashed
um i accept that
facebook tracks everybody so i don't use
facebook right so i accept things i
don't do that with my mom i want to love
my mom
but i can only truly plug into
to my mom when i am truly honest and
i've owned the stories
own the reality and that's hard but it's
necessary
some quick ways you can own that story
is to write your mom a series of letters
about what it was like to watch her
slowly get more and more scared
a way you can own that is to be with
your sisters or your brothers and you
all talk about it too
you are open with each other and you'll
talk about it
okay way you can own it is to be highly
intentional about what your life in the
future is going to look like
and start reverse engineering how do we
get there
because right now this is a story that's
holding you down
and that leads me to this
of the demons of this
so you've heard the phrase um
like bipolar schizophrenia
um there is a strong genetic component
but
i love the way bernie brown says it
genetics loads the gun and environment
pulls the trigger
learned experience sets some of these
things off okay so the wiring might be
there for when x y and z happens so you
go back and you look at mom and say we
don't know what it is
could have been a complex number of
things it could have been a long slow
slide it could have been
that
genetically speaking she had kindling
set up gasoline on there she just needed
a spark and there it went right
and what you're gonna do is start now
working with a counselor closely
getting a crew of people and begin
setting up different experiences that
are different than the ones that are
generational do you still live on the
compound
i do not okay and do you have friends in
community that are outside of that gang
yes do you find yourself leaning into
conspiracy theories and looking over
your shoulders or are you free from that
only when i get manic do i get paranoid
but past there no i moved out of state i
bought a house out of state okay i left
the whole scenario
genetics
some genetics are
this genetic is not a predetermination
this is not a period at the end of your
sentence
okay is it a possibility okay yep i'm
never gonna lie to you it is it is
does it have to happen is it inevitable
absolutely not
well what i'll tell you is
if you live a life without hope
and you live a life of isolation and
running
my guess is i have no data to back this
up okay so this is me spitballing okay
okay the inflammatory processes in your
body
the fear mechanisms in your body
will participate in the switching on of
genetic predispositions to protect you
from what's coming
and so if i'm you i'm going to partner
with a counselor probably maybe even a
psychiatrist at this point
prophylactically and say what do i need
to start doing now thoughts i need to
have behaviors i need to have actions i
need to take community members i need to
be around what can i start doing now and
it might be exercise and meditation and
blob partridge in a periphery all this
stuff
what can i start doing now
so that when i feel the
leanings this away i know okay here we
go and i've got this bedrock of
behaviors that i already leaned towards
i've got this bedrock of thoughts i've
got this community that i can lean on
when things get
here we go here we go here we go right
when it starts spinning and you know
when you're heading down a manic road
right
yeah you can feel it generally i start
getting angry and i'm like why why this
is that why you know you can go up and
then you get everyone thinks it's fun
but it can actually go at an angle where
you're hyper angry at other people oh
raged out and
you also like you it also is like here
we go right because you're going to get
more done than anybody right so it's
both yeah
it's it's a uh it's the worst yeah
listen
you've got hope and if you get anything
out of this call
it's grieve your mom
and
never let that light go out
keep walking towards
that light of hope
okay okay your story's not over all
right your story's not over your tour's
not over hang on the line i'm gonna give
you i'm gonna give you a copy too of own
your past change your future it's
exactly what i'm talking about here um
it's a brand new book it's what's gonna
i want you to read it i want you to work
through it and then i want you to give
me a call back okay
thank you for loving your mom
thank you for doing the hard work coming
up of grieving this is who she was and
this is who she is and i love her for
who she is i got a boundaries got to be
safe and all that stuff and
my future's not over yet
we'll be right back
you all know there are lots of things
that make me nuts but one thing makes me
more nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too
i love living in a new home but i gotta
be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why
because they're committed to doing
what's right for you and that means
walking you through paperwork that's way
over your head that means making sure
you get the right mortgage that you can
pay off as soon as possible and they'll
try to upsell you a bunch of nonsense
that's going to hurt you down the road
and most importantly when you're making
this big life change you can actually
breathe because you've got an expert in
a team who have your back listen if
you're about to buy a home and make a
big change
save yourself the headache and call
churchill mortgage today at triple eight
loan two hundred trust me that's triple
eight loan two hundred
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
1591 in the mls consumeraccess.org equal
housing lender 1749 mallory lane suite
100 brentwood tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and are
not available in all states or locations
all right we are back um
i want to go to this email here from
jonathan in kansas city jonathan writes
this
kelly sent me this and just want to park
on it for a second
i'm a 40 year old guy
and i've never really had a group of
friends my wife is begging me to find
some guys to hang out with she says i'm
suffocating her
what do i do
man
i get this a lot in reverse um
and sometimes this way um
so let's back all the way up when we
answer the story
um up until about 150 years ago and this
is drawing from ester parel's work this
is drawing from terry real's work this
is drawing from some anthropology
talk about this a lot in new book listen
up until about 50 hundred years ago
marriage
it was a work relationship it was either
for wealthy people to expand their power
in their kingdom
or it was for poor people to
just get through the misery that was
life together
and a whole community of people met our
needs
our
existential needs our value needs our
safety needs our passion needs they were
met by people in our church or whatever
myth we were following and i'm going
back thousands of years now our
neighbors our friends our co-workers our
spouse it was met by our tribe
and
over the last 50 years we have pulled
that apart in spades
we have increasingly isolated ourselves
from homes with front porches and
sidewalks to homes with back porches to
homes with now with no porches
to
neighborhood community associations to
facebook groups
and what we've done is we have
increasingly isolated ourselves but our
bodies still need purpose and value in
safety and connectivity and passion and
desire and sex it needs those things but
we've taken them away
and so then we find
jerry maguire
the famous jerry maguire movie
you complete me
shut up you had me at hello right we we
got that
and this idea and it's not just jerry
maguire i'm talking to shakespeare but
this idea that there's a quote-unquote
soul mate
there's this idea that
i will meet the right person and they
will meet they'll make me feel safe they
will make sure i'm loved they will make
sure i'm connected they will make sure i
eat all the right things they will
always be hot we will have crazy wheels
off sex all the time and all of that is
going to be distilled down into one
single person
what do we do we stop making friends we
stop going out
just going to be home you are my thing
and
good folks it's too much pressure for
one person for romance for our
relationships individuals don't have the
tools for it
we've got to have peers and friends and
other men and women in our lives because
we have different kinds of needs now
this nonsense has been used to or this
isn't nonsense but this has been used
for nonsense like we're non-monogamous
and we need to sleep around with
everybody because this person meets this
need that's stupid okay
but what's not stupid is it
it's unrealistic for
and it's unkind to expect one person to
meet every one of your needs all the
time always it's impossible
it's why we watch movies it's why we
read poetry it's why we read books it's
why we hang out with our friends our
same gender friends it's why we have
friends of all shapes
and so when i get a call like this i'm
40 i've never really had a group of
friends
but i found the one and she's gonna meet
all of my needs and she's saying dude
i'm suffocating because i can't be your
safety net i can't be your always friend
i can't be your
tell me everything's going wrong at work
friend i can't be or grab a beer friend
i can't be your okay let's just have sex
too friend i can't be your
mother of your kids i can't it's just
too much pressure
okay
i actually love the new direction of
marriage i love this idea of safety plus
intimacy i love it but we have to get
new tools to do it
we've got to learn a new way of being
our parents
my mom was not allowed to have a
checking account when she got married
that was a law
my dad was a cop she was a
sh i mean she stayed at home
and she wasn't allowed to get a checking
account without her husband's signature
my mom we're talking one generation
and over the last 50 years they just
celebrated their 50th year of marriage
um earlier this year
they've had to undergo a lot of
transition and change now my mom is a
fancy decorated phd professor my dad's a
professor and they've had to figure
stuff out along the way how to
communicate how to talk new tools
so what i tell you that to tell you is
if you are married now
and you're 40 you don't probably don't
have a great picture a great model of
what how does all of this stuff work
together
how does it all end up in the same pot
and we don't drown each other but we
also don't leave each other
how can we feel safe with one another
and still desire each other and how do
we get passion and romance back but also
man someone's got to pay the bills and
you got to vacuum and get the stupid
hairs out of the sink when you shave
it's gross it's disgusting you're gross
how do we do all of that
i'm going to leave you on a set up here
it's not very cool james can i just do a
setup here sorry
buy my new book ah it's so it feels
gross doing this but it's true
the whole book is based about this how
do you deal with these old stories about
how marriage is supposed to go how
relationships are supposed to go and
then what do you do about it
here that's my little tease everybody so
jonathan
sounds like you're suffering
have i got a deal for you 19.95 plus
shipping and handling just kidding it's
not 1995. it's way more expensive than
that not really but
you've got to develop
external community you've got to develop
rhythms you've got to develop a
communication that you can connect with
your spouse and talk about safety and
talk about desire
and sometimes you practice safety and
other times you practice desire
sometimes you practice romance and other
times you practice showing up again and
again even when you're frustrated even
when you're tired all those things take
a lot of work and a lot of effort and a
lot of practice and i'll tell you it is
super worth it
absolutely 100 it's worth it i wouldn't
trade
the new expectations on marriage that i
have that my grandparents have they were
married 74 years
74 years
and they became soul mates because they
went through the grind together and
we've tried to say let's do soulmate
first let's reverse engineer it you'd be
soulmates first and then we'll do life
together that's not how soulmates work
look at how many tools what that looks
like
check out this book here man check it
out here's one thing you can do you can
sit down with your spouse and say
i feel really safe
but i miss our wild sex life or
i want to learn how to desire you some
more would you practice that with me
try that
we'll be right back
big secret
almost all of us can control our
thoughts
yes you can control your thoughts you
choose them most people believe thoughts
randomly happen and that we have to give
rent-free space to bad thoughts and
scary thoughts and freaky thoughts this
is not true
our world doesn't want you to know this
because they want the privilege of
owning your mind no more i want to teach
you how to take back your thoughts
if you often find yourself lost in a
tornado of toxic thoughts and anxiety
and always on high alert you'll have to
be intentional about changing your
thoughts but it is 100
possible in my new book own your past
change your future we'll walk through a
not so complicated approach to mental
health and wellness that includes
learning how to reject harmful thoughts
and cultivate thoughts that move you
closer to who you want to be so go to
johndaloni.com to take the next step
towards wellness that's own your past
change your future at johndaloni.com
hey what's up we are back as we wrap up
today's show this is a third take james
just said the last one was weird so here
we go
we started the show this way we'll end
it this way
songs off the vulgar display of power
record
probably shouldn't listen to it
songs called walk by pantera it goes
like this
can't you see i'm easily bothered by
persistence i'm one step from lashing
out at you and you want in to get under
my skin and call yourself a friend
i've got more friends like you what do i
do is there no standard anymore
what it takes who i am where i've been
where i belong you can't be something
you're not be yourself by yourself stay
away from me
it's a lesson learned in life
known from the dawn of time
respect
walk
walk on home boy